let's get started we're going to talk
about design thinking so design thing
you started here and it's you know it's
a process you've probably seen the
diagram and we start with empathy we
redefine the problem we come up with
lots of ideas and then there's a
fundamental notion I'm going to talk
about this in terms of where because I'm
thinking sometimes doesn't work or
doesn't doesn't it isn't applied
properly there's this this notion of
prototyping and testing or with david
kelly calls building our way forward
that's based on the notion that you know
you don't really understand the user
until you've built something for them
and they've tried you know to use it our
experiences so it's also true that
although that's a nice process I love
this quote I think it was originally
Peter Drucker but I heard it first from
Alan Mulally who was the former CEO of
Ford now mark fields culture eats
processed for lunch I've done a little
bit of Wikipedia searching I think the
original quote from Peter Drucker is
culture eats process for breakfast but
somewhere in the 90s or 2000s we we
decided breakfast was too early so and
what this basically means is that if you
have a if you have the wrong kind of
culture it doesn't matter what process
you use design thinking lean startup
agile it won't make any difference
because the culture will reject the
process culture is always stronger than
the process or programs that people put
in place because culture is that
unspoken rules of behavior in any
organization and that's really how
things get done so we also talked about
the Design Thinking mindsets and
actually you'll see slightly different
versions of this depending on what
version you know of a d.school
presentation you get we also have you
know show not tell you know by a bias to
action and and other mindsets in
slightly different versions but I like
these because I think if you start with
curiosity and you're willing to reframe
your problem if you if you know that
you've got to work across this across
disciplines in your organization and
collaborate radically and you have a
bias to action you are essentially
implementing the Design Thinking mind
your your acting the way designers do
when faced with high uncertainty and the
need for novel solutions so that's just
a quick background now this idea of it's
a method it's not magic is that I want
to I want to go into this notion of you
know design thinking is not
one-size-fits-all and it doesn't always
work and we've got quite a bit of
experience with you know hundreds and
hundreds of companies that have come to
our executive program we're teaching one
in June the innovation master series
master class we also teach boot camps
and summer things and so probably you
know several thousands of executives
have come through our programs taking
these things and gone back to their
organizations to try to implement them
and I think in the last two years or so
I've been noticing because I'm on the
LinkedIn design thinking group and
Facebook group and also it's just you
know monitoring social media and
articles that have been written about
design thinking and you know I don't
know if I'd call it a backlash but
there's a lot of people questioning
whether Design Thinking is actually
effective and whether by applying this
technique you can in fact achieve
significant innovations that have value
to your organization I mean it might be
one thing if this was a method and it
made everybody more creative but
creativity itself is not our goal
because you know children are creative
you know artists are creative but we're
interested as innovation and I would
define innovation as you know applied
creativity creativity applied to a
problem where we can measure the output
and the output and innovation is often
you know market share or or
profitability or and some kind of
increase in a business metric that we
care about so in the last couple years
we've been noticing and taking taking
note of instances where people have
tried to apply design thinking and
hasn't worked or where there's a I guess
you you know there's always a
philosophical argument about one method
versus another I did a the last webinar
I did was on the Lean Startup versus
design thinking what are the differences
whether the
the similarities so I wanted I wanted to
take this time to sort of cover what we
know about the implementations of Design
Thinking and where we find it to be
either less effective or just not
effective at all and and see if we can
untangle those reasons and that way give
people some information on how to
improve the effectiveness of their own
implementation so you know obviously
when we look at this stuff so we can
break we can break the reasons that
things don't work into two pretty big
buckets one is the individuals and
organization what limits those
individuals place on themselves and how
the individuals are either prepared or
not prepared to participate in a kind of
new nonlinear form of innovation and
then of course when you look at
organizations there are organizational
issues that block this we'll talk about
those except they appreciate for it and
then there's what we'll call politics
I've got a little definition of politics
because I just think politics is always
easy interesting to talk about in inside
organizations there's always politics
and it's not I don't even use that as
the negative term I think when you get
I've seen startups with you know three
founders have politics you know around
making decisions and who can say what to
what and and how comfortable people are
you know sharing you know controversial
ideas so politics exists everywhere it's
just a function of you know when humans
get together there's an unspoken set of
things that occur and if you don't
understand them and you get on the wrong
side of politics things don't work I
think there's a tremendous amount of a
political capital that needs to be spent
to change an organization from whatever
it was to a design thinking organization
so we're gonna look at both of those
let's talk about first to individual
limits there's four things I'm gonna
draw somewhat on the work of Professor
Bruce Simon tima at San Francisco State
University he's been doing he's in the
business school he's done a lot of work
studying how Design Thinking does or
doesn't get implemented in organizations
effectively but if you look at just
individuals so if we're going to
okay my company you know new coat we
always called companies new Co in the
valley it's going to be a design
thinking organization I hire a bunch of
people and off we go
well you know those people will not
necessarily have been trained in this
method and they will have other ideas
about ways to work ways to organize
workflows and that's just that
individuals they're coming in to the
organization with those preconceptions
and a certain amount of you know to
perform surmount of human baggage
there's nothing wrong with them it's
just the way people are so we find four
things are true when we look at
organizations across the board and
there's ways you can educate and
mitigate these impacts but but they are
true and if you if you fail to address
them of a less likely good outcome
one is thing people misunderstand the
Design Thinking framework there's a
pretty simple framework but they don't
quite get it right
huge fear of failure this is this is
giant in every organization is a big to
the personal thing fail a feeling of
failure a lack of process practice and
then poor team selection and formation
so let me go to the first one the next
slide no if you look at the cut if you
look at design thinking and I explained
it to you it seems almost self-evident
why wouldn't you talk to people first
define what it is that people need then
iterate prototype and test it seems like
that is although I just spoke with a
friend of mine it's just got hired to be
the director of designing a startup
startup raise 15 million dollars is
doing a relatively technical product
that the product will be a consumer
product they've worked on it for two and
a half years raised 15 million dollars
he's the head of design he got them he
said show me your user user studies in
New Year's Day because I want to build
off of what we've already got and they
said we've never talked to a user but
we're sure they're gonna like our thing
I can't tell you what it is it's not
released yet so you know still companies
don't apply this process but on an
individual basis if you look through
fishing so I think I get it but we find
is that people miss misunderstands one
critical element of the
the design thinking although it's a
simple process is actually based on a
different theory of knowledge a
different theory of what can you know
now a lot of times we deal with
technical companies so therefore with
technical people and technical people
like data they even like data that isn't
real because it just feels good to them
to have some data one one example of a
misunderstanding is they said we say did
you do a prototype and testings with
user they say yeah we did it we did a
survey and we got a bunch of interesting
data about what people like and don't
like and then we point out that at one
the survey isn't an interaction nobody
tried anything nobody they were just
thinking out of their heads and to
survey data is highly skewed by the
questions you ask so there's a survey is
not a prototype but what we find over
and over again is that people search for
certainty and trying to find data about
this thing that doesn't exist yet this
future that they want to build a prop
for and in that future your behaviors
will be completely different because now
you have a smartphone and now you're
doing all these things that you would
never do before
you can't survey yourself into that data
and you can't and you can't spot
experiment and you can't just get five
smart people around the room and figure
out what people want so the problem here
is that underlying the Design Thinking
framework is this notion that in this
theory of information or theory of
knowledge it is you have to admit that
it is impossible to get data about the
future it's simply impossible if those
of you who are product managers out
there in the audience or have done this
kind of stuff before where you've done
user surveys and then you built exactly
what the user wanted and then you
brought them in for a focus group you
said here it is I'm holding it my my
phone here it is exactly what you guys
wanted everything you said and then the
users look at it and they go yeah you
know now that I see that I kind of don't
got trying to change my mind that's not
what I want and that's an example of the
impossibility of understanding the
future because all the users could tell
you is what they could imagine the
future to be but once
provoke them with the thing now their
reality includes this thing and they say
oh well if this is possible
I want something completely different
and that's that's that's the thing where
you cannot get reliable data about the
problem data reduction therefore and
methods of solving the problem like I've
got all the data now all I have to do is
designs up paying our feudal and the way
we solved that problem once you
understand that the theory of knowledge
is that you cannot get reliable data the
only way to get this to sought to
resolve the problem is to build your way
forward build the thing and say is this
it and then they say no and you say well
then what if this were true what would
you want and then they say oh I want
this then if that were true then you
build it again and they say is this what
you want there's you know actually
nobody no no that's not it either and
you continue to do this instead of
collapsing the users understanding of
what the future could be around
prototypes they can actually experience
because it's only through our embodied
experience of these prototypes do we
generate the data of what we want okay
so if you're saying hey we do like to
user studies but we still miss the mark
yeah my guess is in talking to lots of
companies that you're after day that
you're inventing datasets that aren't
accurate but because we're technical
people and we love data it feels good to
get datasets and reduce them to some
kind of a marketing requirements
document or something else and in this
very linear way of working Chris we're
going to talk to the users then we're
going to get the data set then we're
going to write the MRD then the
engineers are going to build it and then
manufacturing is going to make it it
just doesn't work that way and that's
why 60 or 70% of the products you know
that are introduced and certainly in the
consumer field pale you didn't do
anything wrong you just believed in data
that wasn't real so first piece
conceptual problem you have to embrace
the idea that it's impossible to get the
data you need to design the only thing
you can do is build your way forward
that's that's hard for you know I'm
trained as an engineer that's how it was
hard for me to accept it's just a
personal thing I cannot
except that I keep building things and
people keep changing their mind it
almost feels like it's not fair this
gets back to the second thing which is
people to start the panel and every time
you build every time you build the
prototype and you show it to someone it
fails at some level it fails to meet the
mark and you have a hypothesis it's like
inlene we have a hypothesis and then you
do a test you know and it's the build
test you know cycle you you will fail
90% of your prototypes will fail to
solve the problem you were proposing
however they're not actually failures
because they generated a whole new set
of information that you can build with
but people just hate failure we hate
failure we change that avoid failure
become first grade on to the entire
education system it's a huge issue in in
the u.s. but I just got it just kicked
back from a incubator program in Lisbon
and there's been Portugal I've done
programs in Germany we have a sister D
school in Germany in fact in Europe the
fear the stigma for failure is even
higher than it is in the US I think one
of the things that makes Silicon Valley
such a fun place to work is that you can
be a young entrepreneur you can have a
company you can raise a bunch of money
it can totally fail and the venture guys
go hey what do you got what's your next
idea you know so that we've lowered the
bar and failure in Silicon Valley but
everywhere I go around the country and
certainly in Europe and particularly in
Asia the fear of failure is so high that
it actually limits people's ability to
experience their own creativity now we
think that the iterative nature of
design thinking going through these
processes over and over and over again
build up what we like to call failure
immunity or at least insensitivity to
failure because it's not actually a
failure this is prototype something and
then learn something new it feels like
it but it isn't it it's a different
thing so we're not suggesting that you
just you know take a project and fail
that's not that said yeah brakes by
breaking the project into very small
increments and presiding over and over
and over again this is David tells you
fail fast to succeed sooner oh boy
people hate the feeling of failure I do
too I mean it's a failure immunity I
think you just get you
to it I don't know that you ever get
over that fear the next thing is process
practice if I said here's so here's ax
everybody on the team here you you get a
saxophone you get a drum you get a bass
and you get a trumpet okay let's start
playing some jazz well you guys don't
know how to play your instruments right
unless you happen to be your trunk name
so why would you expect to be able to
make good for music on your first sit
down and yet over and over and over
again these organizations come they get
some training you know that I think that
people have been trained in the process
and they understand it pretty well but
they don't do any practice so they just
jump into some big heart problem some
big crazy hairy problem that no one's
been able to solve they get out of
process pretty quickly they resort
resort back to old ideas they get afraid
of failure so they don't test anything
until it's done and then it fails anyway
or they or they don't do multiple
learning teams they hunker down with a
team of like-minded people because
they're the people they can work with
and it's too hard to work with others so
they get out of process and they fail
and David Kelly spoken called kids
confidence he quotes a lot from
psychologist Albert bandura and bandura
called creative confidence self efficacy
the psychological concept that you have
self-efficacy means you believe either
make a change in the world and that your
actions you know are valuable and you
are a valuable person once you have
self-efficacy in one place it's getting
and getting across the board in your
life and he's in the way you get it is
guided master small self-contained steps
where you learn to overcome your fear
and you learn to succeed so again and
again and again we see organizations
plunge in with you know good intentions
but they are but the individuals in the
organization the individual people do
not have practice competence yet and so
they fall back on old behaviors and then
say design thinking didn't work so the
next one I think is is the number
thing that we see across the board okay
so individuals teams are just made up of
individuals if individuals are uncertain
about the process or not really not
really you know have enough reps who the
through the process to own own that
those new behaviors then you put them on
teams and the teams are stressed anyway
because the teams are working very
differently than other teams in the
organization and now we've got you know
I got a I got a learn to be different
myself I gotta learn to be different on
this team and I got a half the time we
also find that these teams in addition
to the Design Thinking exercise their
project they've been given they haven't
been relieved of their other project
responsibilities so they're started
doing it part-time but assuming you have
an intact team and that they've been you
know given a priority on their time to
do this they still need a lot of
coaching because if it's a
multidisciplinary team what you're gonna
find is the people from different parts
of your organization who you used to do
these very formal handoffs with I hand
you a market requirements document you
do an engineering response I hand you
the bill and materials you create the
supply chain when you put everybody
together in one team they they go
through a whole bunch of different
processes we like the model of restock
mint is a psychologist who studied you
know teams and things there's a pretty
famous model out there called forming
storming norming and performing teams
will always go through this you know hey
we're just got on the team we're just
getting ready to go and then as we start
going we start storming because we don't
know who's supposed to do what
eventually if we get through that part
of the process with good coaching and
guidance we get to a normative behavior
we're a pretty good team and we know how
to hand things off between each other
and we know what we're doing and then if
we have a chance to do this in a couple
of different projects we become a
high-performance team because we're
almost intuitively connected in the
process and we know what's next it comes
down to mutual respect it comes down to
understanding what everybody's
deliverables are I was on I was coaching
a team Watson it had MBAs and engineers
on it very talented people in both in
both dimensions and they were trying to
solve hard problems
the engineers deliverable is typically a
prototype for a model of something they
build something the NBA's typical
deliverable is a slide deck which
captures their strategy both are
incredibly valuable and and and at
appropriate deliverable for each
discipline the engineers kept saying one
of the marketing guys going to do
something I say what are you talking
about well they don't do anything just
make slides as well that's what they do
they make slots with such slides it's
that ideas in the slides that important
and and marketing guys kept saying when
the engineers kind of do something I
said well we build all these models they
go yellow but like when are they going
to make this thing the customer wants we
keep giving them slides and they don't
do anything so it parka it just took a
session to sit down and understand this
is what I make and this is how I
contribute my information to the team I
do you know the finance guys does a
spreadsheet the marketing person you
know Chris the strategy the designer
it's a series of prototypes
you know the manufacturing guy tells
everybody you can't make that at a
customer I'm kidding
but that's what they do so if you've
never had to be all on the team at the
same time you never experience that
disconnect and so it's easy to say oh
those guys don't do anything because
they don't do anything like you do so
building this trust building this sort
of set of values I value each of our
contributions is really hard I'll tell
you when we teach multidisciplinary and
we put people on teams from all over the
university confirming the med school
from the business school from the law
school which on a design team it takes
three or four weeks for the teams to get
through the sort of norming and storming
phase and really start to work together
well interestingly enough the teams that
are the most difficult to the vehicle
are often the teaching teams because
you've got the top political scientists
the top computer scientists the top you
know professor of business strategy
they're used to being the only expert in
the room when they get together to
co-teach sometimes it doesn't work
frankly we've had more teaching teams
probably blow up and then student teams
so learning how to work together on a
team and respect each other's values is
really critical moving on it's those are
the so you got you got you got come with
a low fear of failure
to be willing to work hard to learn your
process your instrument you've got to be
able to understand and value the other
people on your team but you're inside a
big organization we find big
organizations can take Vince you know
we've seen fantastic teams that have
formed and stormed and then our high
performance and they really respect each
other I don't know if you saw this
research from Google just recently
published Google's big data companies
that make data where isn't any most of
the time I think but they've been
studying their high performance teams
and low performance teams and they were
doing all sorts of socio metrics and
psycho metrics on the teams it turns out
the only thing they could correlate the
high performance where teams that had
high social trust where they spoke about
things that had nothing to do with the
project and trusted each other as people
interesting data it's all about you know
at the end of the day people but you put
the high performance team in the wrong
environment and they're gonna fail
anyway and then the organization is
going to learn the lesson see design
doesn't work here and we find that comes
to three barriers and then the issues of
politics so the three barriers are
pretty straightforward
conceptual semantics and social again
this comes from the work of Professor
Hyman at San Francisco State these
conceptual blocks are a little bit
around the a little bit around personal
challenges but they come up around the
idea of how do you know how do we have
ideas around here and organizations that
have very strict rules about what's
what's what's allowable thinking and
what's not what you'll find is that
teams norm to the group thinking it
actually impacts the ability their
ability to think of ideas quote out of
the box or however you wanna think of it
out of the culture and so they those
ideas never come up for them and they're
not very flexible and applying their
ideas to the problem at hand
Samantha gaps are as sort of a bigger
organizational challenge and it gets a
little bit to the issue of respect but
it's also just about you know when when
we talk about value in the accounting
department we talk about value this way
when you talk about value
the engineering department stuck but
value this way we think we're agreeing
until we get to the point where it's
somebody has to make a decision and then
we suddenly discover we were not talking
about the same thing at all so small
differences matter people use the same
words to mean different things and they
use different words to mean the same
thing
it sounds like I'm just parsing words
here but it's about how how
organisations communicate and how they
understand each other and and you know
even the term prototype which we use in
design thinking as this sort of throw
away how to ask a good question and
elicit a consumer behavior in the
technical world the prototype is the
thing you build to prove that your
design is complete it's a completely
different thing and a prototype you know
in a business model is a mathematical
thing and so you know just even that one
word can cause collisions on a team
because because huge misunderstandings
and lots and lots of inefficiency and
then there's a sintering thing that
Bruce discovered it's really you know it
is this gets back a little bit I think
to the Google research that it's all
about social interaction there's a huge
number of social barriers and
organizations it's a network problem you
you've probably never had you've
probably never been on a team that was
truly multidisciplinary across
functional you know the engineers to eat
lunch with engineers and accountants eat
lunch with he comes and marketing guys
and girls are brought together you know
for a coffee so the social networks
haven't been built that could support
the kind of radical collaboration and
multidisciplinarity which has got to be
built on these values of trust and
understanding each other's skill sets so
that's just happening in companies that
that happens across the board in every
company you can you can educate around
semantics and and social barriers you
can co-locate which creates you know a
different set of networks and and you
can certainly educate by doing things
like the master class and other things
to up the level of conceptual ability of
any organ
elissa they're really interesting one
which is politics so we've got this
interesting definition of politics it
comes from a consultant that I work with
a lot and him gave Evans as one of the
founders of Electronic Arts has been an
CEO consultant for years and tries to
help CEOs understand politics so
politics he we described it's just the
invisible influence infrastructure they
said invisible you can't see it but
everybody knows it's there and it's the
thing that sort of is under underline
how decisions get made in this
organization like I said you can have
politics in a company of three You
certainly have politics in a company of
three hundred thousand so what do I mean
by invisible infrastructure and and
it'll show you a little two-by-two model
so there's two ways things get done in
organizations I have the power to make
this happen and the CEO I sign the check
and things happen or I decide to build a
factory and then a factory is built I
have the power to make these decisions
so that's authority but then it's also
influence and a lot of stuff that
happens in an organization really
happens through influencing I mean I
have the power to do something but I
have the ability to influence the
decision for instance you know I run the
degree granting program in the School of
Engineering mechanical engineering
school and we give out degrees and my
fantastic colleague Sarah Simon Stein
Greenberg run this executive director of
the D school and she runs the DS schools
educational programs neither one of us
has authority over the other were
co-executive directors in different
areas but each of us influences each
other's ideas and behaviors not get tons
of great ideas from Sarah about how to
improve our program so and I'm sure
you've experienced this too there are
people that you know maybe on the dotted
on the org chart have the actual
authority to make a decision but they
always pull influential people in the
organization to make the right decisions
right
so in this two-by-two you can be in the
bottom left quadrant you can being an
influencer who has no authority on the
bottom right you can be you're gonna
have no influence and no authority
you don't want to be a Nina cos nobody
touch two people with no influence and
no authority on the top right you can
have no influence and lots of a third
you're the autocrat you just tell
everybody what to do and you can have in
the top less influence and authority and
we've go to the next slide I'm gonna
argue that the power zone is right in
that middle on the left side where you
may be you are you know your engineering
director or your marketing product
manager or something product managers by
the way almost entirely move products
through organizations through influence
crop managers almost never have the
authority to tell engineering your
manufacturing core or my sitting or
somebody what to do but they but they're
geniuses at intervention through
influence and I've always thought my
young my young managers that you never
managed to Authority anyway because
pushing people around because you have
power is a very short-term tactic to get
anything done in any organization so I
like this model because it says look if
you want to make a change in an
organization you're going to need at
least the authority to add allocate the
right resources the best use of your
authority or power is to say this team
has space and money and time to do the
thing I want them to do but you're also
going to need to go to the next next
diagram you're also going to need people
who can influence the outcome in a
positive way and this is an interesting
diagram if you think about any
organization that the power zone is you
know bigger at the bottom there's lots
of people who can make small decisions
there are a few people to make big
decisions that's the power zone and
people but they're people influencing
those influencers in the power you know
there's fewer influencers with the CEO
than there are the park manager and this
is imagine this thing is spinning so
people go up and then they get spun out
you know if they turn out to be powerful
with no influence they just get thrown
out of the pyramid so to go to the next
slide change requires that you have an
influencer who has is strategically
aligned with the organization's
this is culturally aligned understands
how things get done around here and had
some record of being successful in
influencing decisions so this brings me
to the next slide is just a little just
a little work chart dependent slide or
uh apologies so yes I thought some cats
will do this first job let's go back to
the org chart that's great in most
organizations that are sort of you know
got any kind of hires you know the way
you move up the hierarchy above the
vertical slice is to be first individual
contributor then maybe a team leader and
maybe you get so manage teams and then
get to manage multiple teams and improve
senior managers managing a whole
function or a whole organization then
there's a difference between bringing up
function to having management
responsibilities for a function and
having people call P&L or responsibility
where it's now you're managing the
business and there's multiple functional
you know pyramids under you so I mean
even in organizations that use a matrix
system or they ever they could say
they're very flat there's a hierarchy of
some sort and obviously there's a lot of
social capital and also just good
reasons to move up the hierarchy if I've
worked 15 years in this organization and
I'm now the vice president of marketing
or engineering which sugars most may be
concerns with innovation I've worked
very hard and established not only my
power my authority but my influence
people believe I'm an influential person
and I'm hopefully the CEO has got not
only you know the authority of that role
but he's got he or she has got the
ability to influence people's behavior
okay so that's the way it is and it's
perfectly aligned with people's
motivations I worked harder I'm a form
I get more responsibility the more
responsibility I can successfully
discharge the higher I go in the in the
pyramid and the better it is so that's
great
everybody's motivations is aligned and
I'm learning from experts who are you
know who manage me and hopefully in a
healthy world that's all good we start
talking about multidisciplinary teams so
we've got a team and the team is
typically across you know across so the
national on the bottom we bring some
marketing people or bring some other
people together and now that team is
kind of an autonomous thing running on
its own and maybe I even empowered it to
just go do the right thing you need more
resources you've got some and that team
is cooking along and they've maybe even
being smart and mindful of process they
picked a small internal problem to work
on first failed a lot then succeeded
built a little credibility picked a
bigger problem now we're starting now
they're starting to get assigned things
that are interesting and impactful and
strategic problems in the organization
and what happens they start hitting what
I call the kill zone typically the
middle level of management sort of
directors vice presidents and things are
starting to notice that a team that is
not entirely inside their vertical
responsibilities is having great success
and is building some social capital and
some influence in the organization and I
don't control that team I can pull you
know a couple people off that team will
report to me because all I have to do
something that's really much more
important but I nicely control that team
it's not clear who control set team and
and it's threatening it's threatening to
things just threatening my influence in
the organization because a group of
people who are much less you know much
lower on the power structure are
starting to develop influence because of
their success and - they're starting to
impact my ability to do the only other
thing that's actually true about
being higher up in the pyramid allocate
resources I get to allocate money and
people to different you know projects
and so there's zero incentive for me to
allow this to continue it's completely
orthogonal literally it's like it's on a
completely different access to my power
structure and my influence structure and
now I know the CEO wants us to be design
thinkers and all but but gosh I've got a
bunch of projects need to get done and I
really need you know Roni to work on
this and I really mean you know Debbie's
work on that I really need John to work
on that and I know you guys need to
travel to visit your customers but you
know we've got this travel budget thing
and I'm kind of not to travel down 25%
so I really can't allow you to travel
I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm not I'm a
team player I'm once now let's design
thinking to succeed but I have a
thousand ways to strangle your team for
access resources influence and power and
I'm not going to be it's not going to be
over it's never over in these situations
and it's not that the vice-president is
a bad woman and she's mean and she just
wants the team to fail it's just that
she's got another set of objectives that
need to be met and and those were the
objectives that made her so successful
in the past and she has no Buy in to
this new structure because it's not
clear how the success of the Design
Thinking multidisciplinary team is going
to reflect on her success and so
although she will not actively try to
destroy it
she will passively not participate one
example of this and it was a story that
AG Lafley told as he was retiring from
Procter & Gamble which is one of the
biggest conversions to sort of design
thinking in a long time but he thought
he could flip the organization from a
kind of a insular organization to when
it was more open and more innovative and
he did it was very successful he said
he's I could do it in three years and it
took eight and at the end he said I had
to fire about 50% of my middle managers
and it wasn't that they weren't
they were just waiting it out they were
like okay this is one another one of
those fads this has happened before
well play along but we won't you know we
won't energetically participate or
problem-solve and they were just sort of
you know killing it killing it slowly
and invisibly by dragging their feet in
a very loop a very reasonable way
because I think people are reasonable in
organizations I don't think politics is
about being evil it's just like I worked
really hard to become the director of
this organization and now you're telling
me that said that role is not as
important as somebody who's just running
around making you know post-its on a
wall and so I don't buy into that and
I'm not going to play
I don't know that firing people is the
only solution to this problem but I
think if you recognize this then then
the one solution that we've seen is very
successful in peace jump show the next
slide is you need two things I always
describe it this way you you have to
have the next one
they're coming we have to have the team
empowered multi-discipline team there
should be a big arrow that's it see you
you need two things you need an
empowered and passions team and on that
team you need a lot of doers so it tends
to be people at the bottom of whatever
you're you know power pyramid is partner
plus pyramid that team has to be managed
by somebody who has tremendous influence
in the organization because they will
need to identify people in the middle
layer to be supporters people in the
middle layer to be advocates you know
and evangelists for them not also need
to identify who in the middle layer they
just need to sort of neutralize or stay
out of the way and only influencers in
organizations know those things they
know the culture inside and out and they
know who they stay away from but that's
that will be insufficient the CEO has to
somehow provide air cover when they were
doing the transition at at parkland
gamble AG Lafley
a special lab he gave them a special
budget they were exempt from other works
they had to do and it was very
successful so you need the air cover
from people with power and you need an
influencer to drive the team we sort of
wrap it up two takeaways you know pretty
straightforward there's four things we
think of that that limit individuals
from participating fully and effectively
when they're so you know conceptual
mints and social barriers the lack of
influencers and the lack of sea level
support whenever we see an
implementation that has not met its
objectives those are typically the two
number one things lack of sea level
support and a lack of an influencer
driving the team so let's and they're
actually the one other thing I want to
point out one large scale transformation
is underway right now is IBM and it's
the largest one we know of the CEO Ginni
Rometty
Jeremy Dias said um that they have to
transform from a kind of engineering
sales culture which is what I've been
spent for years and years into its
design culture and they're using design
thinking as the method Dan Gilbert is a
great pageant charges effort he was a
CEO of a start-up they bought and he's
in he's built the Design Center in
Austin and is kind of educating hundreds
and hundreds of students at design
thinking trained engineers and designers
and then deployments throughout IBM I
was doing two classes a year I think is
300 and he's doing this for three years
so he's got fifteen hundred chain design
thinkers to put all over IP em evidence
isn't there yet and the stock price err
in earnings but there's some evidence
that the divisions are really really
taking methodology to heart and building
at the next generation of IBM software
with this in mind and in certain pockets
where they've implemented this and
introduced new products they're doing
very very well but it says four hundred
and forty thousand person company and
it's a big big task so we're we stay in
touch with those guys and they've done a
bunch of publishing on what they're
doing you can find their stuff on
LinkedIn I highly recommend
with that we have a few minutes to take
some questions from our audience the one
question that that came up was around
the notion of prototyping we are used to
think of prototyping as something that
is relevant for maybe a start-up or a
small new product how does that come
about in a more established company or a
very stablished product yeah I mean I
think it's it's any product or service
or even experience can be prototype to
experience design it so I think of a
great example of experience design as
Disneyland
they design every aspect of your walk
down Main Street reading all designed by
the way to remove as much cash as
possible from your Holly
but the regardless the size of the
organization and again if you're looking
at a if you're in a market place where
you're relatively stable market share
and you're just and you've got a product
and you want to do product you know line
extension a B and C you probably can do
that with a relatively traditional
development process you you know you've
got a when I was at first at Apple and
we've been the first laptops you know we
had some very innovative dimensions of
several of the first ones were quite in
the base because no one had done them
before the next ones were the duos this
was that went in and out of a dock like
a VCR cartridge if you remember VCRs the
third one was you know the first
integrated networking and everything
thing so though in those generational
changes we did a less and less and
prototyping and testing with users the
Venusian Apple doesn't test is silly
it's not true but the but the just sort
of like hey make this one a little bit
faster put a bigger battery in this one
get this one a bigger screen those take
this one that's they're not really
innovation there in your innovation
portfolio their new products but they're
not radically new to our innovative
products so when you it but when you are
faced even in a large organization with
that I think but the real one real value
particularly in a large organization of
building prototypes and insisting on
experiences with actual users this
collapses that whole barrier between the
designers the the marketers and the
users because now there's an object that
we have to all go watch someone
you know play with or simulate playing
with and remember these these processes
can be very simple we do you know user
experience prototypes of a new app by
putting a staff of post-its on an iPhone
and saying the first screen looks like
this second screen looks like this the
third screen looks like this it's really
really low resolution simple things
things you could build in an afternoon
or in an hour so I think it's even more
important in large organizations to get
into a culture of prototyping because
just the prototypes themselves will
collapse that distance between the
people thinking of the products and the
people using them and when you bring
prototypes to meetings it collapses the
semantic problem everybody goes oh
that's what we're making is that more
like I dealt with something else and so
it's a really great way to bring
consistency build consensus in inside
the team and particularly important at
communicating what's the team doing -
you know people in the management are in
the hierarchy so prototypes are even
more important in large positions so one
last question related to the killzone is
I think some of our users or some of our
participants here and commented that the
killzone may not necessarily be at the
higher level it can be all around you in
a variety of ways what are some ways
that you found effective - - to address
that in addition to CEO involvement
which is what we refer to the first yeah
so if you have if you have good air
cover you have somebody who's just going
to keep you know keep the key people
from trying to destroy the team then the
other piece is to have that phenomenal
project manager he or she who has
tremendous influence in the organization
we as a model we said here's the team
then around the team or the people the
team needs to have support from around
that there's a community of people who
just want to know what the team is doing
and then outside of that there's the
people who want the team to fail so
you're managing your support layer and
your community layer and that's why
prototyping and making your work visible
having a huddle room or a boardroom
where all the stuff is all the time over
communicating inside the organization -
so that you when you're not at the scary
new thing that nobody
what you're doing and where you
acknowledge that you need the support of
that that inner circle of people need to
support the project I need to support
from the test group and from the
marketing group and from the research
group so I've got to get them on board
and that's why you need a high influence
project manager to help drive that and
then managing community just outside of
that so that so that your your successes
are the community's successes seem to be
the way to kind of navigate the politics
that are very close to the team and then
every once in a while you'll run into
something somebody who wants to kind of
you know be a roadblock and that's where
all those Scud missiles from the CEO is
helpful the one last question is do you
see a generational gap at all in the
willingness to adopt these kinds of
processes that's a great question
I'm trying to think of instances where
that would be true you know I don't I
don't see any generational generational
gap in this at all in fact obviously
most of the people who come to the
Masterclass they're fairly senior folks
in their organization that you know are
responsible for innovation or for some
kind of a an organization that's that
needs to drive change so I see a
widespread adoption of these techniques
with people who we consider you know
more senior managers who therefore
probably in an older generation you know
the valleys full of companies run by 24
year olds and 22 year olds so I mean
they're they're relatively flexible in
picking a new process because they have
none you know they're not they've not
experienced it before but no I don't
think it's generational I think if
you're in it look if you're in an
organization you know one of those
there's a couple other questions that
are just about like how do you can get
this start now to get your CEO
interested
I think it's was the most of it most of
the time when we noticed someone coming
and saying hey we need some help with
innovation it's because they're really
in trouble we had Mary Barrow the CEO G
GM here
about six months ago and we were
chatting about this and she wants to do
some transformation in her
a huge organization worldwide and and
you know and some people were maybe in
the audience for sort of doubtful of the
you know GM's sort of will to do that
she did look we went bankrupt
what the heck else do we have to do
before people wake up and change
something so if people aren't on board
with changing I'll take care of that I
think he's gonna be I think she's a
great great leader for that organization
so unfortunately her early tenure has
been distracted with some things that
were legacy issues for Jim but I think
typically organization it's a crisis a
new competitor emerges you know unravels
their business model they need to think
fast on their feet maybe they've had a
pretty good time in their market for a
while and so they haven't developed a
muscle to be you know rapidly innovative
and so too oftentimes they come in a
time of crisis although I think you know
a really great leader would go WOW if
we're doing really well right now why
don't we go invent the disruption it's
going to come instead of wait for some
22 year old to do it in Silicon Valley
why don't we go invent our own
disruptive technologies and so I I see
you know really strong visionary leaders
taking that approach as well hopefully
you don't have to wait for a crisis yeah
so creating a sense of urgency is
helpful but not necessary so I want to
thank Bill Burnett again for this really
insightful webinar and create a little
bit of a sense of urgency with all of
you folks to hopefully register for a
next webinar and also visit us here on
campus for the innovation master Series
in June and get a chance to soak up more
of this really great content and and in
vivid and see all this in person with
that I want to thank all of you for
joining us today you should expect a
link with a recording of this webinar
within a week and we hope you have a
good rest of your day